[MUSIC - TRAIN, "SAVE
ME, SAN FRANCISCO"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "IF
IT'S LOVE"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: All right, hold
them up so I can take a
picture and then tweet
it to you.
And then you guys can check
it out on Google later.
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "IF
IT'S LOVE"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Thank
you so much!
I'm going to take some pictures
over here, so I'll be
right back.
Can I have some lights?
I don't know how to
do this thing.
Is it like that?
OK.
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "MEET
VIRGINIA"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Does anyone
remember the song?
[CHEERS]
PATRICK MONAHAN:
Thank goodness!
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "MEET
VIRGINIA"]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Hey,
thank you all.
Hey we're Train.
We're from San Francisco
as well.
Thanks for having us to
this amazing party.
And uh--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
a picture.
PATRICK MONAHAN: Oh, OK.
Yeah, I'll be right there.
I love you.
So this is our latest single.
It's called "50 Ways to Say
Goodbye." It's about a guy
who's too embarrassed to tell us
friends that his girlfriend
left him, so he just tells
everybody she passed away.
It's reasonable.
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "50 WAYS
TO SAY GOODBYE"]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Hey, thanks.
I think we wanted to do this
next song later, but it seems
like we should do it now.
It's just make sense all more in
the whole scheme of things.
And I'll start it out.
It goes, way down inside.
Woman, you need me.
[MUSIC - "DON'T STOP
BELIEVING"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: I've
got the words here.
Does anybody think they
could tackle this one?
You got this?
Seriously, you sing?
You look incredible.
You think you could throw
down some vocals?
Come on!
She said she's a terrible
singer.
But you're so cute,
no one will care.
Except everybody.
Ready?
[MUSIC - "DON'T STOP
BELIEVING"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: I can't sing.
Hold on a second.
Hold on.
We're gonna be--
just hold on.
I just needed that to happen.
Just stay here for a second,
because we want to give a
guitar away tonight, and
I wanted to see if
maybe you wanted it.
Can anybody sing better
than that?
Is there a dude that wants
to try to do it?
All the guys just like
to record everything.
Who's got this?
Seriously?
OK, you got this?
All right, come on.
Run.
You have to run, run
like the wind.
Yes, sure, yes.
Jump, do it.
Yes, awesome.
Did you get carded before
you came in tonight?
You drinking tonight?
But you're not driving, right?
OK, here we go.
You know this one?
[MUSIC - "DON'T STOP
BELIEVING"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: You're not
supposed to be better than the
singer, bro!
All right, I'll take this one.
[MUSIC - "DON'T STOP
BELIEVING"]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: I love those
of you guys so much, I can't
even believe it.
One is going to end up with a
t-shirt this evening, which--
we've got the best freakin'
t-shirts in the business, let
me just throw it out there.
And the other is going to go
home with a signed guitar.
But I can't decide because one
of you is so attractive, and
then there's you, honey.
You've got great long,
blonde hair.
And I just don't know
what to do next.
So I'm going to leave it
to you guys to decide.
Would you call the winner
my best friend, Carol?
[CHEERS]
PATRICK MONAHAN: What is
your name, by the way?
KATIE: Close--
Katie.
PATRICK MONAHAN: I meant K--
OK, you got a lot of votes.
I wouldn't take the fact that
no one cheered for you.
Don't take that personally.
I mean, it happened for us
the first four songs.
And everybody's laughing because
you know it's true.
Mean is funny.
How 'bout my second best
friend, homeboy?
[LOUD CHEERS]
PATRICK MONAHAN: All right.
So Katie, it looks like
you're the winner.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: All right,
kid, you earned it.
The cooler people in the band
will sign that after the show.
And Katie, I'll see
you backstage.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK MONAHAN: What's up?
We're best friends.
Happy birthday.
Thank you, I love you, too.
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "CALL
ALL ANGELS"]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: (SINGS)
Oh, swear to ya.
[WEAK CHEERS]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Seriously?
Do you not know this one yet?
We'll just play it until
you're singing along.
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "DRIVE BY"]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: (SINGS) Hey!
[CHEERS]
PATRICK MONAHAN:
That's better.
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "HEY,
SOUL SISTER"]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Thank
you very much.
So before we leave, I would
like to say, sincerely on
behalf of all of us, how proud
we are to have been invited to
this event.
Because Google, it's as big
as it gets and it's
as cool as it gets.
And my only problem, I suppose,
is that when you look
up "train" just pictures of
awesome locomotives come up.
I don't know who's in charge of
that, but I'd like to see
that person removed from
Google right away.
But [LAUGHS]
other than that, you
guys are perfect.
Thanks for everything.
It's a real honor to
be here for us.
And it's an honor to be
from the same place
you guys are from.
Thank you.
[CHEERS]
[MUSIC - TRAIN, "DROPS
OF JUPITER"]
PATRICK MONAHAN: Hey,
thanks so much.
Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]